talk about the downgrade for the first
time in history of us credit by the
agency Standard & Poor's why did S&P
drop the rating they lack faith as the
US government has the political will and
the kind of discipline policy making to
deal with our net problem and deal with
in a responsible way and as a result
they they feel that we are no longer a
triple-a rating or no longer an
ultra-safe form of debt for investors
around the globe to hold and so they
downgrade us to double-a instead of
triple-a what about the Congressional
debt and deficit bill on Tuesday did
that have any effect here well I think
what they were just funding is thought
that the bill was passed obviously if it
had not passed and we had defaulted on
our debts that would have been even
worse but they felt that the process
that got there was not one that
suggested that there's going to be a
reasoned and steady progress toward
deficit reduction over time it's not the
u.s. who's incapable paying its debts
the problem they identified as we may
lack the political will the governance
the had a good political decision-making
to get there and arrive there in an
orderly way how is this going to affect
interest rates we don't know for sure
we'll find out starting next week when
the up markets open monday morning but
it's hard to imagine it'll be good for
interest rates what could very well
happen is the global investors say you
know maybe if this is no longer triple-a
asset maybe i want to demand a higher
interest rates to hold this debt so it
might mean the US government has to pay
more for to borrow money and those rates
tend to trickle through to other
borrowers so if you're trying to get a
mortgage if you're a company trying to
take out a loan this could translate
into higher interest rates across court
now what about the other rating agencies
they have so far not been inclined to
downgrade Standard & Poor's and more
aggressive than the other two major ones
Moody's and Fitch you know the question
is what it would take for the others to
take the same approach and also
downgrade we don't know quite what that
line looks like but if we continue to
have a very divisive political process
and an unwillingness in Washington to
arrive at a desk reduction approach
strategy and you could imagine the other
rating agencies cutting their ratings as
well so we were at triple-a we're now at
a double a plus what would need to
happen to get that trip
a rating back it's hard to know that you
know these are these are very opaque
processes we don't know for sure exactly
what the line is for senator bores what
they would need to see to change their
mind what we do know is historically
when a country has been downgraded it
takes time it's not as if you can be
downgraded and then a month later it
gets reversed these can be multi-year
process and the question is do we over
the next few years in the United States
government in there a steady process
toward short more thoughtful
deficit-reduction the way that so far
what kind of impact do you think this
could have on the international economy
uh it's again hard to say we don't you
know you're never seen this before we
don't know quite what will happen what
we do know is that when when there's
disruption of the financial system it's
hard for dick so if you remember when
lehman brothers went bankrupt in
September 2008 there is no obvious
reason that should have called the
global financial crisis and yet it did
and US Treasury bonds are deeply
entrenched across the world financial
system in all kinds of different ways so
people in the government are not
expecting some kind of economic collapse
starting next week but they are nervous
and know that you know there's a lot we
don't know about how this will play out
Neil Irwin with the Washington Post
thanks for your time thanks for having